okay it's time for hatred mail hatred
mail of course when a professional
voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the hate mail that I receive
day in and day out quick reminder about
hatred mail Hey we probably poison our
entire family if Trump told us to but
remember it's not a cult Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay we have a new word coined
here I'm going to ask your help in
getting this one into urban dictionary
if you successfully get this word into
urban dictionary please send me a link
of course there should be a definition
that references the David Pakman show as
there is for the word hatred fever --nt
and maybe some others I'm not sure now
that word is feed a pile feed a pile
okay not pedophile we're reversing and
the word is feed up I'll take a listen
to this Pakman you are the part of the
problem because you compare Trump
narrative with Nazi narrative about Jews
but Nazis are lying about Jews like they
are filthy etc and Trump never said and
you Dems just handle the true my gay
friend told me long time ago to said to
me everybody can call me with any bad
names and I don't care but when somebody
call me fedo pile just because I am gay
then I am really pissed off and that
your narrative is gonna be the key for
Trump win in 2020 this is just something
else feed a pile Nazis Nazis na z IES we
can't handle the true this is not
autocorrect ladies and gentlemen this
actually seems like a lack of spellcheck
more than more than anything else I
don't have an explanation for it I just
present it to you and I'm asking for
your help in getting the word feed a
pile into urban dictionary that is pH e
do PIL e remember the best way to fight
hate reott ism in your community
is to sign up for a membership to our
show using the coupon code hey tree at
40
that's h80 RI o t 4-0